good evening members and officers of the
council and members of the press and
public I welcome you to this meeting of
the council if the fire alarm is in fact
is activated please vacate the offices
via the stairs either through the
security doors
to my right or opposite the lifts in the
foyer please do not use the lifts please
assemble in holy square on the green
offices will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber the Proceedings of this meeting
will be recorded and subsequently
broadcast on the internet I would advise
that if filming takes place anyone in
attendance in the public areas may have
their image captured
I urge anyone filming proceedings to
avoid filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
does anyone intend filming the meeting
any member of the public who objects to
the possibility of being filmed may wish
to take this opportunity to leave the
meeting any filming or recording will
not be permitted for any item of
business where exempt or confidential
information is considered following the
exclusion of the press and public from
the meeting would everyone present
please ensure that their mobile phones
are turned to silent and that they are
not used to make or receive phone calls
in the chamber while this meeting is in
progress
agenda item 1 apologies for absence
apologies that were received from the
following councillors Evans Linda Potts
Roy parts councillor Larkins and shank
are there any other
apologist thank you
I move that eliminates of the meeting of
the council held on the 13th of July
2017 be approved in signed as a correct
record would the vice chairman please
second my second that madam chairman do
members agree thank you I am sure
members would wish to join me in
welcoming councillor Venables to the
meeting congratulations on your recent
election it is with regret that I have
to announce that Jerry Glover has
recently passed away mr. Glover was a
counselor from 1995 to 2003 and was a
cabinet member for economic development
and part marketing between 1999 and 2001
I'm sure council will join me in
expression expressing sympathy to mr.
Clovis family
could all members please stand for a
minute's silence as a mark of respect
for the late mr. Glover
please be seated does any member wish to
say a few words
councillor Johnston thank you very much
chairman there are a few of us here who
will remember Jerry from the early days
when we were all elected in 1995 and the
one thing you could say about Jerry very
strongly was that he was a straight
talker and the thing that he did most
that I remember of him with his absolute
commitment to supporting Senate in its
regeneration and economic development
and it's always very sad when we seem to
have a regular time at these meetings to
stand up and sing the praises of people
that we knew before Jerry and I had many
a squabble because tourism and marketing
actually was my portfolio and he had had
economic development in regeneration and
I had to make it very clear that tourism
was a major part of regeneration and
culture was a driver for it so we did
have those ups and downs of time but
Jerry was my friend and I went to his
funeral as did Bob sitting in front of
me and former leader and Richard
Nicholson and there was a very good
turnout for him at Minster Church
recently and what we could say for Jerry
he was born in Scotland he spent some
time he had thought he was going to be a
priest at one time had been to Spain and
when we got grupo antal and thanks to
his work and particularly Richard
Nicholson's when we got grupo antolín
coming there was somebody there who'd
actually been in the seminary with him
in Spain suddenly realized that was a
priest had actually done the course
Jerry came back stayed strong in his
faith marries Joyce and hadn't rushing
at for children I believe he managed to
take on at that time but for me many of
the things that we achieved were thanks
to that team thanks to that money that
we got from Europe and from government
here he was very clear in his thinking
he eventually came around to the way of
thinking that tourism was important
which is really important for me and in
later life he needed our help
I'd like to say particularly Bob because
we're not on the same political side in
any shape or form but you were a great
help as his ward councillor in
supporting me when I was there I mention
it in front of it I was the leader once
here in trying to get him rehoused and
officers officers here were terrific Bob
Porter in particular when we needed to
help Jerry who had helped thousands of
people actually in his own life and we
then were able to help him start passing
for us in the Labor Party and sad for I
think the people of Minster Thank You
councillor Grove yes thank you madam
chairman I speak more on the parish side
of of Jerry because that's where I where
I first met him the first parish meeting
and I found him a man that came straight
to the point there's never any beating
around the bush with him he turned out
to be a very good friend to me and he
guided me through parish politics some
of the time with an acidic tongue but
after them
Oh
councilor grove couldn't please put your
microphone on sorry I thought you could
hear me with a voice like this he worked
hard to achieve a better Minster for
people and all whether playing surface
pitch a skate park a BMX park and also
he had great dealings with the the match
and making of the roundabouts at the top
of the hill for minster all I can say a
dear friend that he was to me
he left minster a better place and he
never gave up working right until the
end he was a good counselor Thank You
councillor Kane Gregory thank you madam
chairman well Jerry Glover both he and I
joined the council in 1995 I believe
when anything with the red rose it would
have go elected because of that time and
if we're one and Jerry and I became
joint whips for the Labour group and
that was a very interesting thing Jerry
had the character for being a whip he
was as mentioned mentioned before he did
have a bit of a tunnel pony but also he
had the sixth sense if you like when he
knew that things weren't going right and
he was able to highlight them and Zone
in upon them and deal with it I was on
the cabinet with him as planning and
transportation actually we had many an
argument but we always respected his
viewpoint because he was a tenacious
councillor and if he wanted something
he'd fight to the very end even if he
didn't get it it still carry on fighting
but I have to say that's the character
it seems you need to be a good counselor
and Jerry represented his constituents
brilliantly he did a cracking job and
I'm so sad when he lost his sight
following the operation that he had but
he turned up again in Minster as a
parish councillor and with the opening
of the hair of the dog a Minster the
little pub he was in his element there
because he could sit at the bar and the
red wine would flow quite copiously and
he would get much more verbal as the
evenings went on always very interesting
but the great fun was of course and I'm
not mocking his affliction of the time
which was he lost his sight but if you
kept your mouth shut
he couldn't
- because he didn't know you were there
but Jerry as I saw I worked closely with
for many years greatest respect for him
and I'm sure many members of our group
who worked with him and against him at
the time look back on him and think
that's the sort of person we need as a
counselor that was Jerry thank you for
that agenda item number four
declarations of interest are there any
declarations of interest agenda item
number five petitions one petition
returns to Council in accordance with
council procedure rule number 12
agenda item 5 a petition regarding 2017
Hawkin charges this item is to report
the council's response to the petition
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme would bood members
please note the report thank you
agenda item 6 questions from the press
and public one question has been
received from a member of the public in
accordance with council procedure rule
number 13 please note that only the
questioner and the respondent are
permitted to speak on the question and
that if the questioner is not present at
this meeting their question cannot be
put but will be replied to in writing
could the questioner please only state
the name of the cabinet member to whom
their question is to be put and read out
the exact wording of the question that
they submitted to the council agenda
item 6a a question one from a member of
the public regarding the president the
presence of far-right hate groups in
Thanet I am pleased to welcome miss
Crawford to the meeting could you please
make your way to the top table
jogo yes
all right thank you Willis Council
condemned the presence of far-right hate
groups internet the white lives matter
March last year in Margate which enabled
people to talk blatantly about eugenics
outside the turn of contemporary and the
plan Britain first rally on the 14th of
October cannot be acceptable in our area
I'm also concerned that TDC hasn't
endorsed Amnesty International's
declaration on racism just a question
thank you miss Crawford I call apart I
call upon the leader to respond thank
you a question I'm happy to confirm this
council condemns the presence of
far-right hate groups in sallet as well
as any other hate groups they are not
welcome here whilst we condemn their
presence both TDC and the police do have
a legal obligation to facilitate
peaceful protest
thankfully there is a great deal of
experience in planning for and policing
such events available to us based on
current information officers are like
expecting any serious disorder from the
protests taking place on Saturday 14th
October 2017 however we are assured that
they will have resources in place to
deal with any issues that may arise on
that day thank you
agenda item seven questions from members
of the council four questions have been
received from members in accordance with
council procedure rule number fourteen
question one from a member regarding
rough sleepers
I call upon counselor matter face thank
you chair my question is to council a
reverend piper could the cabinet member
please give me the most up-to-date
statistics for rough sleepers and the
insecurely housed in senate I've called
upon counselor reverend piper to respond
Thank You chair as with many who take on
a role like this I guess you think until
you get in the chair that you know a
little bit about the subject and then
when you get into the chair you realize
just how little you do in fact you know
so I am indebted to the team for helping
me to answer this question then it has
seen a significant increase in rough
sleeping in recent years up to a high of
33 people at the last annual official
estimate which was late autumn 2016 a
further official estimate will be
produced this year to coincide with the
collation of national figures and this
position is a reflection of the national
picture the number of rough sleepers in
England has increased by a hundred and
thirty-four percent since 2010 to a high
of four thousand one hundred and
thirty-four noted during the autumn of
2016 a significant cause of these
increases is the growing unaffordability
of the private rented sector making it
much harder for people on low incomes or
reliant on Housing Benefit for their
housing costs to find a suitable home in
addition to rough sleeping there are two
and a half thousand households
registered on the housing list who have
a housing need including households
living in
secure accommodation overcrowded
conditions or with disrepair problems
during 2016 we dealt with 880
homelessness applications and
successfully prevented around a third of
those households from actually becoming
homeless we estimate that there are
approximately it is an estimation 6,400
homes with the category 1 hazard that's
based on the statutory housing health
and safety rating system and for further
information about nine and a half
thousand households living in fuel
poverty councillor Matta face do you
have a supplementary question I do chair
regarding the insecurely host it would
have been useful to know how many of
those have actually been found
accommodation infinite as opposed to
elsewhere but my follow-up question is
relating to those of us who were here on
the briefing on Tuesday as we heard from
acting superintendent Pritchard on
Tuesday evening at the briefing rough
sleepers who clearly are a growing
number and the number is considerably up
on the 33 you quoted are vulnerable to
attack and being preyed upon the winter
shelter is a short-term measure and
hopefully it will be fully operational
again this year so can I ask what the
cabinet member and Thanet District
Council are doing to find a longer-term
solution to this growing problem
counselor Reverend Piper would you like
to respond
I too was at that briefing and we got
some very interesting information and
statistics provided not least by the
police are on this subject
I've also recently this week attended
health and well-being meetings and also
housing meetings and home the
homelessness forum and it has been
reported to us that the project will run
again this winter there is every
confidence that will it will be at least
if not more successful than the project
that was run last year and I have every
confidence that as our experience
as a counsel in dealing with these
matters grows and increases we will in
fact achieve more successful outcomes I
haven't had my question answered asked
about finding a longer-term solution
just give me a short-term solution
I'm sorry counselor Matt's face that's
his answer agenda item 7b question 2
from a member regarding invest Fallot
planet
I call upon councillor Johnson thank you
very much chairman could the leader
please confirm if anyone has been found
to replace the chair of inverse salad
thank you I call upon the leader to
respond yes thank you question two
following the resignation of the last
chair invest Anna the council has been
considering how best to redesign the
investment board deliver the economic
growth strategy published last year by
the council I'm delighted to say that
the new chair has been identified we
were making the name of this position
known in the autumn when we have also
had an opportunity to confirm other new
board members to lead and support a
series of working groups that we hope to
put in place Council Johnson do you have
a supplementary question thank you very
much chairman I do welcome because it's
at least a year since there's been a
chairman and the working groups we set
up hadn't met now my supplementary
although we congratulate Hastings and
Folkston on their recently announced
good fortune and getting even more
inward investment can can we have
confirmation that the leader himself
will personally attend all meetings
where there is an opportunity to put
Sonic's name forward it's really the
duty of the leader and the cabinet
member for regeneration to attend these
meetings and I noticed from the minutes
that I've been checking that the leader
does seem to be noticed by his absence
can he confirm to the meeting this
evening that he will attend as many as
possible of these outside meetings and
I'm talking about partnerships all over
the county and indeed in London thank
you
I call upon the leader to respond yes
indeed quite right the cabinet member
for regeneration is the main contact
within the investor net board I have
spent more of my time on multi agency
activities and others across the wider
southeast in Kent as a whole and indeed
that's part the reason why I've taken up
two national body positions this year in
order to actually spread the word about
what we have to offer thank you
agenda item 7c question three from a
member regarding the proposed Britain
1st March
I call upon councillor Constantine
costume for the leader what steps is the
council taken to limit the negative
impact on the community of Thanet of the
proposed Britain 1st March and October
the 14th given that this group is racist
xenophobic and in light of the recent
atrocities in London Manchester
Barcelona Finland and Charlotte Ville
and other places I call upon the leader
to respond thank you thank you a
question and some repetition from
obviously the earlier question Kent
Police are aware of the protests taking
place on /t 14th October and it advised
that policing will be proportionate and
that they will endeavour to minimize any
potential disruption to the local
community as I said it before the police
have an obligation to facilitate
peaceful protest and have a great deal
of experience in planning for and
policing such events and based on
current information they're not
expecting any serious disorder we will
be holding meetings with partner
agencies where we will look at practical
steps necessary to facilitate this with
as minimum impact as possible and offer
public reassurance we've already met for
initial discussions it will continue
this work to offer reassurance to the
public as further details become
available we do have a good history
working closely with our partners with
regard to protests in the past were
appropriate we've held joint briefings
for potentially affected local residents
and businesses provided updated
information as soon as it becomes
available and ensure the area returned
to its usual clean state as soon as
possible post protests and providing
local knowledge those looking
the policing of such events whilst we
absolutely condemn any violent conduct
but asked everyone to support ours and
Kemp please in keeping the other planet
a safe and peaceful place to be
councillor Constantine do you have a
supplementary question I do have a
supplementary question you'll be aware
that the council has a public secretary
quality duty to foster good relations as
a way of tackling prejudice and
promoting Understanding between
different groups of people a recent
report by the charity hope not hate
outlines how after public attitudes
towards Islam have got worse with 52% of
the population say in Islam poses a
threat to the West
so my supplementary question is given
this council as public sector equality
duty and the rise of fear towards one
section of our community
ie Muslims what further steps with the
council take to promote and foster good
relations I called upon the leader to
respond this council has so as far as
I'm aware a good track record stretching
back not just in this administration but
for others in doing its best to foster
good relations as of where it can across
the island as a whole I will explain
that to continue and not necessarily be
blown off course by a specific element
of a specific March and a specific day
okay agenda item 7d question 4 from from
a member regarding the return of ferry
services to Ramsgate
would members please refer to a
supplementary agenda number one I call
upon councillor Beauford Thank You chair
what the cabinet member for regeneration
Enterprise Services advised us to what
progress has been made towards bringing
a ferry service back to Ramsgate
I call upon Council estimates might seem
to respond Thank You chair and Thank You
councillor David
the first thing we had to ensure was
that the port was ready for any
potential ferry operations including
additional dredging which allowed us to
accommodate the gaff coke our
importation to encourage a new operator
and to make our position absolutely
clear regarding how the port is actually
a vital strategic asset in the southeast
we developed and submitted a very
comprehensive southeast local enterprise
partnership bid for further investment
in terms of a second double deck berth
and off-site the logistics hub and a
potential extension of the port as part
of this process
officers presented a very robust
business case to KCC and several
government departments and also lured
Heseltine the then chair of the Thames
gateway Commission and whilst our bid
was not successful it did raise the
profile of the port significantly
following the feedback from this
exercise we had to clearly define both
the benefits to potential operators of
the port and how the services we can
provide are different to those
especially of Dover but we can provide
is pre-booked
just-in-time service for the accompanied
freight market in the first instance not
only because of the close proximity to
the major UK motorways and short
crossing times but also because the port
is not affected by operation stack for
freight companies operating out of
Ramsgate the cost of delays and having
their vehicle is stuck on the m20 would
be a thing of the past
to do this we appointed a port
consultant with over 30 years of
experience in high high profile
positions within the cross-channel
market and a successful track record of
developing new business models
the consultant has been working with
officers to develop a user guide for the
port which provides in principle a full
business solution for a ferry operator
to just plug into and this has been
presented to the logistics market ferry
operators Vestas and other cross channel
ports we are also now part of the
recently established Kent strategic
Freight group which brings together all
the interested parties in what is an
international transport corridor vital
to the UK's national economy this
includes all the relevant district
councils courts Eurotunnel ferry
operators highways England Kent Police
local MP and DC LG as you will be aware
from recent media articles the team have
actively engaged with the whole cross
channel market both in the UK and Europe
and established positive relationships
with all the major players and the
profile of the port has never been
greater the team are seen as highly
professional and extremely competent and
there is no doubt that the port is both
open and ready for business
councillor braeford do you have a
supplementary question I do chair yes um
thank you for that answer the last ferry
left Ramsgate in April 2013 over four
years ago and the longer we go without
ferry service in there I think the less
confidence people have that one is going
to return so could I ask you to tell the
council please what is your plan B I
called Punk our estimates seem to
respond thank you
well plan B I would refer you back to
our options paper of July 2015 which is
still current and
pretty well pretty well up to date and
in there we have a number of options and
I'm sure that the document is available
for you to look at the options include
there is other other Freight elements
and we feel we feel that we have
adequately covered that point thank you
agenda item number eight motions on
notice no motions on notice have been
received in accordance with council
procedure rule three agenda item number
nine the leaders report I call upon the
leader thank you madam chairman
if you forget the day-to-day work of our
council staff often working hard behind
the scenes to deliver services to our
residents every day of the year as
councillors we tend to focus on failures
rather than successes because it is the
failures in surveys which residents
bring to our attention when their
frustration boils over yet over the
recent bank holiday weekend which saw us
receive and welcomed more than 120,000
visitors to the island when many
councillors noted the difficulties
around parking and the impacts the flood
of tourists with the good weather our
teams were hard at work even if we
individually did not see them we
collected over that weekend some 95 tons
of rubbish over the bank olivey from
seafront locations alone ie beaches and
bins virtually all swept an empty by
hand between six hard-working team
members as there was little chance the
mechanical street cleansing being used
on the crowded streets over the same
period of that banqueting weekend we
issued some 176 fixed penalty notices
for parking infringement and in passing
I'll also note that in spite of the
gloom merchants predictions car parking
income between 1st April of the 31st
August was 92 thousand pounds up on the
same period last year and more than 1120
roads and parking permits for the high
season car parks have been issued G
August we inspected some sixty three
outlets under environmental health
legislation and it took 14 revisits
issuing nine formal notices
instigating volunteer closures for deep
cleans to ensure public health we issued
some 284 littering fixed penalties on
the streets in August as well
the task force approaching cliff hall
West one of our hot spots starts at work
just last Monday working together with
community group ABC a better
cliftonville promoting better
understanding of responsible tenant and
resident behavior we've been invited to
present our work to bear down on rogue
landlords are both a conference in
London in July and on the back of that
presentation on participating the
officers at the ready 17 conference in
Newport just next week showcasing the
work of seaside towns on Housing and
regeneration challenges at the
conference in London I heard a
remarkable statistic that sort of lived
with me ever since
nationally 20 percent of the population
live in privately rented property and of
that group 17 percent rely on Housing
Benefit in the selected licensing area
in cliftonville the only selective
lasting area in the southeast some
seventy percent of the property is
privately rented I love that 70 percent
is housing benefit dependent a
staggering statistic in the context of
the national average and it probably
explains why we have so many challenges
to face that's one of the areas where we
face up the many issues that clearly and
calmly we face there was cross-party
support for the winter shelter program
or referred to during the course this
meeting where cancers for all parties
gave time energy effort to make it work
23 of the 25 regular users of that
scheme are now off the streets and
housed that in one sense astonishing 92
percent success rate hides the sheer
number of hours and hard work needed to
win the confidence of those 23 and
change their habits at the same time
this year we have been had the most
difficult year for
trouble incidents for some years some 42
reports of incursions this year it's
probably unsuspected some 5 years ago
the numbers of instance was a mere 5 all
of these are harmful some are genuine
travelers here for a short holiday
victims of our own successful
advertising I suspect it will visit and
move on fairly quickly I'll often leave
a very tidy sight behind them we don't
have problems and every encampment but
where we do have groups who create
problems and create issues we are
I've been very unsettled with within the
community we do have a robust routine
for dealing with this 24 hours to move
all unless there are exceptional welfare
circumstances and after 24 hours we
instruct legal services for written
order and that's usually where the
delays begin how quickly the court
process is carried out varies on when
the case could be listed for a hearing
and when the summons is issued sometimes
our issue for the same day sometimes
it's some days away sometimes it's
rehearse cause of the bank holiday and
so the process can drag on and if
another vehicle arrives on site during
this period of time it becomes a new
incursion and the process and the
illicit issuing of paperwork must begin
all over again we continue to win
government funds to pursue the housing
issues on our island the first southeast
Council to win cash from the migrant
impacts fund working with homes
Immunization to deliver social housing
and we continue the policies of previous
administrations to bear down on the
scandal of empty properties empty and
direct properties have an adverse effect
on neighborhoods they are unsightly and
can attract crime and anti-social
behaviour such as squatting arson
graffiti and fly-tipping
they also affect the value of
neighboring properties by creating the
impression of neglect and decline within
a community
they are certainly a wasted resource in
the time of ever-growing housing need
long term empty homes of those that have
been empty for more than six months
because we expect a natural turnover
under that time scale of houses are
bought and sold
fala has more empty homes than any other
kent district and our action on these
matters over some considerable period of
time makes us the highest performing
counseling kent ringing empty homes back
into use in 2016-17 TDC broad 126 empty
homes back into use through intervention
we worked closely in partnership with
KCC's now us empty initiative to deliver
interest-free loans and ensure long-term
NT homes are renovated and brought back
into use the renovated homes must be
sold or let after renovation loans are
awarded in units of 25 thousand up to a
max of 175,000 pounds for applicant and
must be repaid within two years for
loans to sell in three years for loans
to let TDC also introduced empty home
loans for owner occupiers in the Margate
central and cliff for West area in
17 financed by ours and administered
through KCC's know you sent initiative
these loans are for up to twenty
thousand pounds are interest-free for up
to ten years
applicants must live in the renovated
home for at least five years and the
property must have been empty for more
than six months since 2012 whichever
party has led this council our councils
housing intervention program has been
purchasing long-term empty properties in
Margot and Ramsgate and converting and
renovating them to create new homes for
affordable rent which have been retained
by the council and managed in our behalf
by East King housing in May this year in
spite of budget pressures we increased
capacity to undertake more robust empty
homes enforcement by appointing a new
mentor property officer who will focus
on the most difficult and complex areas
that require bold action to bring about
change action like has happened with an
empty property in cliftonville in very
poor condition lighting the neighborhood
councils served enforcement notice that
was ignored we then took action or
elevated the property externally and
when the owners failed to repay the cost
of came out the works in default we
enforce the sale at auction as
mortgagees not in position to recover
the debt and we now have a new owner who
intends to convert the property and
create a number of much-needed new homes
since 2013 council tax has been charged
one hundred and fifty percent for
properties that have been empty for more
than two years our successes over many
years have given us allowance for some
600 or so properties in the local plan
numbers to offset against our expected
total this continuity of policy across
council administrations has truly helped
local residents see both their housing
needs as individuals and in saving some
greenfield land from development it is
worth noting however that both
governments our main opposition at
national level remain committed to
building more houses as a national
policy objective the chief planning
inspector has recently indicated that
any local plans not filed by 31st March
2018 will then be subject to a new
method of calculating housing numbers
there are no signs that number will be
lower so any continuing position of
being without a Local Plan after our
council vote on the subject in January
2018 takes huge risks with our quality
of life here in Summit where many
residents feel the proposed housing
numbers are already too high
never has it been so clear that we need
the protection of an adopted local plan
against developer incursion we will have
to have a truly mature cross-party
debate about housing sites and numbers
in the coming months to achieve that and
I leave you with that thought
commending this report this evening to
the council I call upon councillor Baker
to comment on or ask questions in
relation to the leaders report yeah
Thank You chair I welcome the many
positives in the leaders report and the
endorses appreciation of the efforts of
our staff over this very busy time in
the summer they do a sterling job but
more often than the recipients of
brickbats rather than price I also
welcome the change of tone in tonight's
leaders report not only are there no
side swipes other political parties
there's even a recognition of the good
work done by previous administrations
the only negative is that I don't feel I
can be rude about it tonight which is
what I normally do what whilst it's good
to see so many visitors come into Thanet
I'm concerned that the concentrated
numbers in certain places gives rise to
public safety issues just as an example
and and not because I live there but it
just happens to be a good example in
Kings guy Josh and botany Bay's were so
crowded over some weekends that people
were going in vast numbers onto Kings
gate Bay there are no toilets on that
Beach which gives rise to potential
public health issues and there are no
lifeguards and as there as many people
in the water I see that that's a very
real risk further the huge number of
cars and inconsiderate attitude of many
of their drivers created a situation
where emergency vehicles would have
struggled to attend any incidents these
problems were replicated in other places
on the island impacting heavily on the
quality of life of some residents I
think the time has probably come for a
critical review to see whether any steps
can be taken to manage the negative
impacts of tourism perhaps it could be
possible to direct visitors to more
appropriate places
to consider deploying our enforcement
officers more effectively certainly
there are many people that feel that the
heavy publicizing of some of our beauty
spots has been too effective that's too
good I'm pleased to hear that our empty
property strategies continue to be
effective and that the various housing
interventions are ongoing it is
disappointing I agree with the leader to
hear how many of our residents in
Cliftonville are in private rented
accommodation and drawing Housing
Benefit with regard to the local plan
you're absolutely right to point out the
risks of not having a new local plan in
place and the potential consequences of
missing the 31st of March deadline what
won't be right though leader is if you
use those factors to pressure members
into approving a plan in January that
they're not entirely happy with and I
think we all know what the elephant in
the room is in that one however on a
much brighter note I'm surprised that
you didn't mention the opening of the
new Weatherspoon's on Ramsgate seafront
it's an impressive transformation of a
previously sad looking building and I'm
sure it will be a great success even
though it will bring even more of those
pesky visitors I call upon the leader to
respond I thank you for that you did say
a while ago if I wasn't political you
wouldn't be so thank you again for that
I think it's the first time I've been
criticized for having too effective
advertising what we do and I think that
so and I honestly felt that we've
probably done enough to publicize
Weatherspoon's in recent weeks it seems
to have dominated the news and dominated
of the television interest in the area I
was interested we went down to the
internet slide Wetherspoons the data
tube for has opened a Helen count the
BBC political reporter said to me rather
sadly that she'd been there an hour
knocked on every door of every pub and
Club she could find in the area and not
one of them not one of them want to
condemn the opening of where the spoons
they were all pleased at the footfall
was coming and it took I locally-based
Ramsgate journalist from The Guardian to
find one to quote which appeared Adair
so light
yeah it's great what's not to like about
4.5 million pounds worth of him good
investment into a building that Seth
Aaron's been rotten and derelict for
some time and creates 120 to 150 new job
particular on how you count those
full-time equivalent and the more of
that we can do all of us in our
different ways the better it will be and
I hope that we can report even more
tourist spending even more money per
head and perhaps spending their time
parking their cars happily at a good'n
but to actually see their way forward I
call upon councillor Matt's face to
comment on or ask questions in relation
to the leaders report Thank You chair
I'm surprised councillor Beauford didn't
mention the enterprise and farmer
decided to open his lower field at a
fiver a time and undercut TD sees
parking charges at Joss Bay but will
move on
you mentioned mechanical sweepers they
aren't any use when you've got parked up
roads in large parts of Ramsgate parts
of Broadstairs and Margate so we do
still need the men and the brooms please
because they do a great job and women
sorry do a for large men women and
people with brooms I've already
mentioned the winter sheltering concern
Council of Reverend Piper's mentioned it
could I ask if the same generous
anonymous donor will be able to help
fund the Winter Shelter this winter to
enable even more vulnerable rough
sleepers to have a bed for the night
and with the leader also be give credit
to the medieval interior seas especially
the Salvation Army staff who helped on
it last year hopefully the advertisement
which I have in my hands if any was
looking for a job hopefully the
advertisement for an organised of
closing date this Sunday will produce an
excellent organizer to take this very
worthwhile project forward
now last year there were seven locations
in use and I was wondering whether the
use of so many locations is essential or
is it better perhaps to have one as a
focal point for the rough sleepers
because I know what happened when they
were left when they left in the morning
they tended to drift back to their old
haunts they were being moved from
a Shinto location and I just wonder
whether we could maybe look at one one
value rather than seven and we were
promised at the end of the winter
shelter period that there would be a
review but I don't recall having seen a
report and I have no idea what changes
have been proposed
hence my question why far the point I
would like to make the Winter Shelter
closing social I went to Phillips's a
very good venue by the way and I got
reprimanded by one of the graduates from
the Winter Shelter because I did not
recognize him
and he said don't you recognize me Jenny
and I'm delighted to say this man had
turned his life around and there's
another member from the shelter there
who had done the same but what I would
like to ask of the 23 who were found
accommodation has only followed it
follow up on their progress been planned
because it would be interesting to know
if they've stayed here if they stayed in
the location and whether the gentleman
who reprimanded me for not recognizing
him is still helping with the
fundraising I was a regular volunteer
they even quite like my cooking which is
a bit of a plus but I found it
disappointing that tough love which Ian
Buckland introduced did not work for
everybody
and it was a little bit disheartening
when I came on some evenings just at
Luke's and Ramsgate to find them hanging
around the gates and they weren't
allowed in it was like detention at
school but the other way around in
actual fact so could ask what plans
there might be in the program this
winter to modify the issues that led to
some being asked to leave and can we
perhaps expect to see the leader or his
cabinet assisting in some of the
kitchens final point I'd like to our she
mentioned empty properties some of those
are owned by TDC so could you please
give me some sort of update on the fort
hotel and I was very sad to see that
store 21 is empty a very large unit down
Margate High Street
perhaps some progress with the empty
stores that we own as well as empty
properties owned by possibly absentee
landowners would be quite useful thank
you
I call upon the leader to respond quite
a listener I making up for last time I
got the paper this time you're on the
empty property outside the the homeless
winter shelter scheme we're looking at
all options yes there are pros and cons
in having them in different places there
are pros and cons having in the same
places as opposed to spreading it around
getting the volunteers to work near
where they want to be what could point
make a case either way I'm not gonna try
I'm gonna leave that to the
conversations that go on with the
churches and the volunteers who chief
want to be involved on happy to mention
any particular group or groups of
volunteers that help I think they came
from all over let me shadow of a doubt
it's very hard to differentiate with
people who are in in great need but
certainly those who are using drugs or
maybe not in the best of moods given
their alcohol intake are not necessarily
ones that we want to actually have in
position and that we're light to be able
to do much to actually help at that
stage so I think that we'll still
continue to be some degree of tough love
involved as well as I'm aware all 23 of
those he went through and funny enough
I'm bit what recently he was actually
living in porch light and and a very
different young man - when I last met
them have been often support we've seem
to do so I understand that the anonymous
donor is likely to come forward again
this year we're yet to have the final
confirmation of how much and I believe a
report was published we didn't reach you
I apologize we'll make sure it does come
to you I think you'll probably hear
something about the fort Road hotel in
the forthcoming cabinet meeting we
talked about assets and I really have no
idea on store 20 or more have a look
I call upon councilor growth to comment
on or ask questions in relation to the
leaders report yes thank you madam
chairman
it's a good report I think it's great to
hear especially about empty properties
coming back into use on under the
jurisdiction of TDC and also what I find
good tonight it's two archenemies
actually starting to talk and be friends
to each other for Mises what are the
steady or steady on then okay let's not
say archenemy let's say anyway it's it's
great also forum said I think with the
Weatherspoon's opening but I think the
only only downfall of Ramsgate now is
the seafront itself which needs sorting
out this is not really a question but
possibly lady you cannot so it's an
observation I did make in your report I
find it rather disappointing when I find
TDC worked so hard and is strapped for
cash but still tries to do things for
people that are down announce and yet
with the travelers once we've taken out
a call cost in removing the travelers
one more vehicle needs to turn up and
they're new and the whole process has to
be start up again now knowing and having
dealing with in certain applications
which will remain nameless when they
don't apply to rules in certain
applications I've dealt with that they
put another manager in as soon as the
TDC is going to come down hard on them
so I think this small needs looking at
because if the travelers are clever
enough they're moving and a weak like to
another vehicle to turn up and in a week
like and after that another vehicle turn
up and infinitum we will have such cost
on our hands here be astronomical
perhaps a leader could look into that
law and me get it changed thank you
I call upon the leader to respond yeah I
appreciate the point I appreciate what
you're trying to say if it was within my
gift I would sign the paperwork tomorrow
but I think you'll find it's part of
national legislation and maybe even some
sort of human rights law and rather than
fall out with my colleague our
agenda item number 10 report to the
chair chairman of the overview and
scrutiny panel
I call upon councillor David Saunders to
present his report Thank You chairman
members I would confirm that since we
last met on the 13th of July seems an
awful long while ago
both the overviews and scrutiny panel
and the subcommittee working parties
have met on two occasions of the
subcommittee's you will see that the
Dreamland working party met for the
fourth time on the 31st of July and
their conclusions are detailed in 4.3 of
this evenings papers having concluded
the Dreamland exercise and with resource
available a working group consisting of
all panel members has been formed to
conduct a review of the draft of local
plan through free workshops members you
will recall that when the developing
draft local plan was considered bioview
scrutiny in November 2016 panel members
were concerned that insufficient time
had been given for them to study the
report in depth
hopefully by adopting this workshop
approach panel members will be better
equipped in terms of time to scrutinize
the report and make in-depth
recommendations prior to the final
submission of such an important and
wide-ranging document and the leader has
already intimated that we're on a time
schedule here and I'm pleased to say
that the workshops have been dovetailed
into the timer schedule so that
hopefully panel members will have
sufficient time to study the sound bites
that we receive rather than the massive
papers we received last time so we're
looking forward to that there will be an
interesting session or interesting three
sessions members I commend the report
and I'm happy to answer questions thank
you
councillor Beauford oh you look
surprised at all honest picture um uh
well may be disappointed yeah it's not
really a question it's a voicing the
concern really I've been a member of the
cabinet Advisory Group looking at the
local plan for years you know years and
years and years and I'm not sure that
some of the nuances of that plan even
now I'm totally sure of and certainly
the way things have changed and keep
changing you know to keep abreast and
really understand what's in the local
plan it's quite difficult it's a massive
document you've seen thousands of pages
and you know good luck to the members of
our view and scrutiny in their
scrutinizing Oviatt but really I don't
know that you can do proper scrutiny in
four meetings and what concerns me is
that I'm sure that they will do a
sterling job they would do the best they
can for what worries me is that if at
the end of the day they come out with
anything like a positive report that
will be used as an endorsement by the
leader to actually further push through
the particular agenda that he's
following
councillor Saunders would you care to
respond I can assure that my leader
councillor Bay furred that yes I've
already laid the foundations for members
of the panel to post questions in
advance to the workshops we will be
looking at the time schedules and I
think the last exercise in 2016 was a
learning curve I certainly learnt to
speed read and it's like reading my
daily paper you tend to know where to
look to get the answers that you're
looking for and the areas that are shall
we say standard and non-contentious so
hopefully we will be able to scrutinize
the developing draft local plan in a way
that allows us to come back with some
meaningful recommendations thank you
agenda item 11 annual treasury
management review 2016 17
I call upon council at alland thank you
chair the annual treasury management
review sets out the treasury management
strategy for the last year and actual
performance regarding the council's
borrowing and investments the report is
consistent with past reports in that a
great deal is dependent upon interest
rates rates have been at historically
low levels for a considerable time and
experts believe interest rates will rise
modestly in the near to medium term the
report was considered by governments and
audit committee on the 28th of June and
cabinet on the 27th of July I move the
council notes and approves the
recommendations
is there a second
counselor Ian Gregory Thank You Jenny I
must say I was very pleased to see
counselor John town in sitting there
tonight because if you look at the front
page of the report this is the only one
where the portfolio holder isn't named
it just says the portfolio holder for
finance in the States so it could've
been anybody who turned up so I could
remand the victim as far as we knew but
anyway anyway congratulations again to
the treasury management team they've
obviously steered the council finances
through a particularly volatile period
in relation to the ups and downs of
interest rates for various reasons
national and international but I do have
a couple of questions that I'd like the
counselor turns in to answer if he can
in annex one it does mention there the
facts that the the bank overdraft
benchmark was exceeded only for one day
admittedly but it was exceeded and I
wonder if he has any other information
as to how that came about and if in fact
there was a process being put in place
to make sure that something that it
doesn't happen again and secondly as far
as the HRA is concerned slightly down
under table 1 it says that the capital
expenditure budget was repro filed for
the HRA account and the if this hadn't
been done obviously the capital
financing requirement would have
increased by six point seven million and
my question is was the capital financing
requirements rich or was it repro filed
I should say because the East Kent
services haven't once again managed to
do all of their capital projects
complete their capital projects or was
it actually done to reduce the capital
finance and requirement by six point
seven million thank you
councillor Anand Thank You councillor
Gregory
firstly I'm I'm very glad you recognized
me I'm also disappointed that halfway
through your diatribe
you called me councillor Townsend there
is no s in town but nonetheless I think
we're even now
where are the guards to the first point
on the one day omission or delay I'm
sure it won't happen again or we're
certainly ensured that to do everything
to make sure that doesn't happen but it
wasn't serious anyway and of them on the
second point we will certainly get back
to you with the things there are an
awful lot as you are well aware in these
reports thank you
do members agree thank you agenda item
12 changes to committees panels and
boards 2017 to 2018 would members please
refer to a supplementary agenda number
one proportionality as described within
the report consensus on the options has
been achieved between group group
leaders so unless any members wish to
propose an alternative option I propose
option 1 as shown on the supplementary
agenda with the vice chairman please
second second MNR Jalen no members agree
thank you joint transportation board
would members please refer to the
members notes I move that council agrees
the proportionality between groups for
the fanuc district council seats on the
joint transportation board as shown on
the mem in the members notes would the
vice chairman please second I second
that madam chairman do members agree
thank you
nomination of members to serve on
committees googley leaders should take
this opportunity to the rise of any
changes to their nominations to
committees panels and boards for the
remainder of 2017-18 I call upon the
leader okay madam chairman
I'm not going to nominate all of those
this evening I have a number of members
on holiday able to contact I will advise
the other group leaders and Democratic
services as a when those petitions are
finalized okay I call upon council bifid
yeah almost the same chair Aldi sponsor
mr. Hughes and told him that
we'll be in next week okay thank you I
call upon counselor Matt's face Thank
You Chuck I'm planning where we have
doubled our representation our delegates
are at sorry representatives will
because the fenner and myself with the
two reserves counselors Campbell and
constant time on licensing I'm delighted
the council Johnston is going to join me
no change to offer even scrutiny and
governance audit Council of Venables is
going on governance and audit and
councillor Campbell is being removed
he's been kicked off he volunteered it's
okay he volunteered yeah you do have to
break there are no other changes
councillor Johnson is our representative
on Jane joint Transportation Board and
I'm glad that this time with the
supplementary the numbers were correct
once the schoolteacher you know we don't
have eight we have at seven and that's
it thank you very much thank you
I call upon councilor Grove now you
madam chairman no change thank you thank
you
agenda item 13 representation on outside
bodies I call upon the leader chose a
change for about by changing portfolio
holder so that the change would be to
appointing the camp counselor reverend
piper in place of counsel in fairness on
there a second
though members are great thank you and
that concludes the business for this
meeting of the council